i've been reading a lot of rumors um i
wouldn't bet on it there wasn't any room
to fit it in the narrative and the story
i was telling in the performance
um so yeah there's there's no special
guests
speaking with the nfl network's kay
adams the weekend sets the record
straight
rumors had run rapid about possible
appearances from his
former collaborators like ariana grande
kendrick lamar and even daft punk
but looks like the weeknd doesn't need
any help his new album the highlights a
compilation of his favorites from his
own music
just became spotify's most streamed
album of all time
yes the weeknd knows we can't get enough
so he also gave us a first look at his
last meal ad for the big game
which at first was peaceful but then
sunday night's ads will be filled with
more great canadians from michael buble
to mike myers who reunites with his
wayne's world counterpart
dana carvey the two joined jimmy fallon
last night to talk
about their uber eats ad with cardi b
which is also part of a relief effort to
support local restaurants
many many millions many many millions
that are
going to be supporting local restaurants
so it's yeah let's see it's
20 million good for you it's very nice
a nice element to doing in the the honor
and flattery of being asked to do a
super bowl commercial
and then the fact that it has a nice a
nice uh
philanthropic another canadian making a
super bowl ad appearance is dan levy but
before that he'll be hosting saturday
night live with musical guest
phoebe bridgers we are pumped so excited
phoebe since we've been bonding this
week i wonder whether you could like
maybe write a song about me or something
i think i'm good on that thanks i think
so cool i will oh great ready
and while dan seems calm at a table read
for the show
his shit's creek co-star annie murphy
gives us the real intel
all he's said is that he's going through
very very kind of eerily calm
moments and then just being walloped
with words and it's just
it's just going back and forth between
those two